- cécécécécécécécécécécécécécécs
exceptionnelles.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premieststststre du Canada
- Le gouvernement fédéral
invoque la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgences.
nationale, la situation
intenable.
- Et on n'accepte pas que
les gens viennent endommager
notre économie et faire mal
de leurs concitoyens par
des manifestations illégales
- Poste frontière bloqué
au Manitoba, saisi
d'armes en Alberta.
- Freedom!
- Pendant qu'à Ott
les manifestants prennent
leurs aises après18181818181818.
Le gouvernement n'entend pas
déployer l'armée, mais octroie
aux policiers des pouvoirs
exceptionnels.
Protéger les infrastructures
essentielles comme les aéroports
et les postes frontière etmamams
de 5000 $ et des peines
jusqu'à 5 ans de prison.
au financement étranger.
Les compagnies de
sociofinancement devront
rapporter aux autorités
les dons dounsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsns
pourront geler des comptes
e e e e e e sans préavis.
- These costs are real.
- Le gouvernement vise
directement le gagne-pain
des manifestants récalcitrants.
ministre du Canada
c c c c c camion est utilisé
dans ces blocages, vos comptes
l'assurance de votre véhiculese.
- L'On
la plus touchée, appuiel'initia.
- It's game over. There is zero
toleranc
- Mais d'autres premiers
ministre
aux mesures d'urgence fédérales,
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Au Quépapapapapapapas
ces problèmes-là
et deuxièmement, faut être
prudent. Actuellement,
de l'huile sur le feu.
- Les organisateurs
de l'occupation disent qu'ils ne
sont pas intimidés et
ils serrent les rangs.
À Ottawa, l'opposition
conservatrice émet
des préoccupations.
- La décision qui a été prise
aujourd'hui par le premier
ministvevevevevevevevenimer
la situation plutôt
que d'apaiser les tensions.
- Les mesures d'urgence entrent
en vigueur immédiamais les parls
auront un droit de regard et
ils en débattront aux Communes
et au Sénat, d'ici 7 jours.
ALAIN THERRIEN, député, BQ
- L'attente pour le
ne peut pas durer sept jours,
il ne peut pas y avoir de chèque
en blanc alors qu'
pouvoirs extrêmes.
JAGMEET SINGH, cuvuvuvuvuvuvuvue
- Où était le première ministre
depuis des semaines?
Pourquoi il a seulement décidé
- Justin T
ne pas prendre cette décision
historique à la légère.
de créer un précédent
en déclarant l'ulelelelelelelele
contre des manifestants.
Mais pour l'opposition,
ces mesures exceptionnelles
est un aveu d'échec.
Ici Chris